i remember we started filming um
i i got paid half
uh towards the beginning
and um 32 000 after taxes came to like
20 000
and i got half of that so i received a
check for ten thousand dollars
and um when i found out that i was going
to receive a check for ten thousand
dollars i called up the
director jeff tremaine and i said yo
dude i'm about to get a check for ten
thousand dollars and that
isn't even gonna be cleared i'm gonna
put it in the bank and before it even
clears into the account
i'm gonna be in my car driving
out to california i was in florida at
the time and i'm gonna drive
you know i'm gonna put it i'm
like driving out of delhi i'm
moving out to l.a to ride this
wave and uh
and jeff tremaine said that he said
you're not going anywhere
until you send me a list of ideas
to film in every state between
florida and california and if the list
is on point then i'll fly out a
production team to follow you across
country and get all this footage on the
road
so uh so that's what we did and it put
me way ahead of uh
of the game for a shooting for for those
you know
for the third season i suppose um and
yeah that was the deal man i moved out
there and i got out to california and
everyone was like dude
you know you better strike while the
iron's hot man you know you're
you're the show's gonna be
canceled you're gonna it's kind of
this moment's gonna pass and i found
that frustrating because i was just
trying to like
be in the moment yeah and and and that's
like kind of
everybody was a little bit right you
know i mean they are right like
up to that point i viewed all of my
video footage
like in sort of like a dark like
religious kind of a way
that like we're we're all going to
be dead
but i want to live forever and when i
videotape something that video
can play after i'm dead so i won't be
dead at all like i'm gonna live
forever and i had this like
this super like just like the
sacred view of like the immortality
of video footage you know footage is
forever like ah
you know right there's this huge
importance to what i was doing
but then when i got out to california
and everyone's like oh it's gonna be you
know
just strike well there and taught like
it really dawned on me
the footage is not forever you
know that
when when you're uh doing when you're
actually in the game
the footage has an expiry date you know
like
the footage comes out and then it just
spoils
you know like once you're down once it's
rotten and then like nowadays
that's gone like now what are you gonna
do you know and then and
life turns into this uh this really
frantic desperate pathetic like you know
chasing the spotlight around and try to
always have like
and and and like like what like where
what's next you know like what do you
got next it's just this scary
daunting question like you you have
to have something next or you're
you know you're only as good as what
you're doing right now